hi this is damon root for a reason
television i'm here today with josh
Blackman professor of law at South Texas
College of Law in Houston and author of
the new book unprecedented it's the
constitutional challenge to Obamacare
now obviously is over the over the two
years as the legal challenge to the
health care law was was working its way
through the courts was before the
American people that the word
unprecedented was thrown around a lot by
the Challenger it's it's an
unprecedented exercise of federal power
it's an unprecedented attack on on the
on the individual citizen what did what
made you choose this title for the book
well the Obamacare law was very much a
first in several respects it was
unprecedented in that never before had a
lob in past such magnitude that any
Republican volume it was impressive in
the fact that it never before had
Congress for people do stuff I was also
unprecedented in the way which was
passed kind of ramped through the last
minute without deliberation Randy
Barnett a law professor at George John
who was when the leading architect of
this challenge kept using this word over
and over again say that this law is
unprecedented that Congress had never
done this before and at an event I made
an offhand comment to my blog saying hey
we should have a Randy Barnett drinking
game we know we take a shot whenever
randy said unprecedented and if we did
that we'd all be drunk on the floor
please at every five minutes and Randy
actually said later that that
crystallized in his mind the power of
that word they did that Congress is
doing something that had never done
before has a lot of rhetorical force and
less people understand how grave this
law is so in deciding in the book this
was definitely the right title because
this was an unprecedented case you talk
about how how the case well first the
health care law itself and the way it
was passed and then the legal challenge
is it gathers steam it creates this sort
of constitutional moment in America and
and and it and it and it is energizes
tea party activists it energizes people
on both sides of the debate terms
talking about the Constitution that's
not unprecedented American history but I
mean you make a very strong argument
that that is one of these moments that
we're going to look back and see that
this is when the Constitution and
debates about our system are really at
the forefront right i mean the period
from 2009 the 2012 was remarkable
the first time you had a strong
constitutional movement pop up out of
nowhere the Tea Party this wasn't
organized this wasn't happening kind of
a a founding cause it was just people
who had a dissatisfaction with the scope
of the federal government in their power
and at just the right moment President
Obama gave him their exact gift
Obamacare and this was like the fuel for
their movement and people weren't
objecting to this law purely on policy
grounds I mean they didn't like it was
going to waste money and it was bad
policy but they said this is
unconstitutional the Constitution does
not give Congress this power and
rallying behind Obamacare their tea
party grew magnificently and we saw in
2010 the republicans gained so many
seats in the House largely in the backs
of voting against people supported obama
care and in 2012 it kind of faded away
because by that point the supreme court
had already upheld the the law so so so
the Obamacare law actually kind of
represents a full art of the rise and
slow descent of the Tea Party I would
pause say that I think that the Tea
Party movement is lying dormant it's
lined or because the sentiments against
this expansion are still existing it
just would require the right trigger to
bring it back and i think one aspect of
the obamacare case is a federal
government should be leery about what
kinds of exertions they make people like
nancy pelosi thought there was no
problem with this when people said is
this constitution said are you kidding
me i don't think people in the democrats
particular appreciated how divisive such
an issue was and they pay the price for
it going forward I think we'll see
Congress maybe not being so keen to pass
laws such a large scale out of fear of
what will happen let me let's let's talk
about the Chief Justice John Roberts and
his opinion and and and the arguments
are though the reasoning that goes into
it and you really have a very thorough
discussion I mean I really have the
whole case from from from every aspect
and it's and it's and it's also I should
just I just like to add I mean it's you
it's incredibly gripping account I mean
this is you have a you have a minute mad
minute break down second-by-second
granny form of yet like that's right
lecture 24 of the of the decision day as
it comes down but the chief justice he
I mean as we all know he upheld the law
heap sort of formed this coalition with
with the Liberals on the court to do so
but but you you you and you make this
point several times in the book that he
rewrote the law you say he upheld a
statute that Congress did not write I
mean can you explain what do you mean by
that ok so when Obamacare was passed in
2009 we have to remember the president's
campaign pledge in 2008 the president
said I will not raise taxes that was his
pledge so in framing the Obamacare law
they were very deliberate the way the
Obamacare law works is that if you don't
have health insurance you have to pay
this penalty and the statute called it
just that a penalty it wasn't called
attacks but as the litigation proceeded
one of the arguments that government you
use to support it was saying listen this
is just a tax we are just taxing people
I'm not having health insurance but the
statute didn't say that the statute
called it a penalty was very clear so in
order for the Chief Justice to uphold
the statute he had like make-believe
time like mr. Rogers he said well even
though it says penalty we're going to
pretend you know I make believe that it
says tax because if it's said tax then
we could uphold it piece of cake no
problem so John Roberts in his opinion
called a saving construction upheld the
law that Congress never wrote this is a
law that Congress could have never
passed in 2010 because have they called
it a tax they have gone slammed at the
polls and in the public opinion this law
was passed without calling it attacks
and I was upheld by calling it attacks
the response to the decision you know I
would group it into two broad categories
there's sort of a political partisan
response if you like the law you're
happy with the lobbying upheld if you
didn't like it you're unhappy about it
but then you look at the response among
legal experts law professors legal
scholars it was it's more complicated
actually more interesting where you had
liberal legal academics very prominent
ones who basically supported the law
thought Congress had the power to enact
the the individual mandate under the
Commerce Clause they were quite upset
with Roberts ruling because he rejected
that argument and for conservatives did
and then you have sort of libertarian
conservative law professors challenging
law they actually see a sort of a
victory for some of their ideas
are they let me put it to you this way
are the are these liberals right to be a
little upset at the outcome of the case
another libertarians a little right to
be to be cheered by the outcome Damon
that's exactly right when this case for
start in 2009 is a laugher I'm I talk
about in my book how at the 2009 federal
Saudi convention in Washington right
here Randy Barnett myself and a few
other lawyers were just talking about
this case and at the time no one thought
there was any way the Supreme Court
would ever have a single vote in the
other than justice thomas to strike this
down but fast forward two and a half
years and this argument gained steam and
gained traction and started to be
accepted by judges and some scholars and
then we go to the Supreme Court where
five justices say that Congress can't
regulate inactivity seven justices say
that the federal government can't coerce
States into accepting this Medicaid
money holy cow we can put aside what
this means for the future and what what
doctrinally this means but the court
made it very clear that the so-called
federalism revolution of the rehnquist
Court is still ongoing and that the
court will police the bounds before the
federal government can and cannot do and
this opinion makes very clear that the
structural protections of our
Constitution the doctrine of enumerated
powers like the Commerce Clause of
federalism between the states and the
federal government those matter and they
don't just matter in the abstract those
are the key bowl works in protecting our
freedoms and our individual liberty and
the fact that you had five votes for
that I think is really significant and
it should represent a shift in the way
people approach this so I said before
that perhaps the governor might be Lee
or even passing new laws this your
factor into it because you now have the
strong constitutional under current in
the people about what the federal
government can do you have the Supreme
Court on record saying there's certain
things government can and can't do and
this actually is not so bad for
libertarians this actually might be a
good recognition that the Constitution
has very strong libertarian principles
embedded into it there are still some
big challenges in the courts towards the
law what do you make of the prospects of
any of those so there are a couple
lingering challenges one involves the
so-called contraceptive
mandate this law says that employers
have to provide contraceptives and
abortion procedures to their employees
and the argument goes well my business
is a Christian business i running a
craft store and i run it with a
Christian virtue or on all my employees
to be devoted to christ and it goes
against my religious beliefs well it's
not really your believes it's a beliefs
of your corporation but the court has
held that corporations do have certain
constitutional rights and within the
next year the court will consider one of
those cases of whether the government
can force a Christian oriented or Jewish
oriented business to offer these pills
or these products it's a tough call
another challenge involved a so-called
Medicaid exchanges because this law was
passed so hastily there are a lot of
things that didn't really make sense and
the way the laws were in now if any
state's decide not to participate in
Obamacare the people in those states are
not allowed to get subsidies for the
health insurance HHS said now we're
going to it anyway and they're probably
breaking the law and those cases should
resolve the next few months their number
of lingering cases but I think
ultimately the Chief Justice decision
saved Obamacare I'm not too convinced
that any of these repeal or defund
efforts will work no matter how many
commercials we see for it because this
law is a law of the land we're kind of
stuck with it that might be a bad thing
I'd be a good thing but going forward i
think the lesson we have to take from
this is how the constitutional element
progressed so quickly and flourished and
when we saw that the Constitution when
the federal government went too far and
what they did the American people clawed
back and I think we will keep that ethos
with us going forward as we develop the
Constitution and in response to the
growing power of the federal government
thank you very much Josh Blackman author
of the new book unprecedented the
constitutional challenge to Obamacare
thank you so much Jimmy thank you for
recent television I'm David rhew
you